hey guys the office has been quiet this
week partly because everyone's ill but
mostly because Lucy's been away in Japan
a fact that's made two more bitterly
jealous tam what are you doing it should
be me Dave I should be the one in Japan
she doesn't love it like I do stop
wearing the same shirt as me so to
placate am this week we're doing anime
better tan specifically anime that
deserves a good live-action adaptation
Hollywood's already got his hands on a
Keira ghost in the shell and death note
they here are six anime that we think
deserve a shot on the big screen
fist of the north star is one the few
enemies that you consult in an elevator
pitch fist of north stars Mad Max with
martial arts if that elevator pitch
isn't good enough for you to buy what
I'm selling maybe you should get out by
elevator the classic anime and manga
series has everything you could want
from an action movie an enigmatic here
with amazing eyebrows a post-apocalyptic
wasteland full of kung fu biker gangs
and badass fight sequences where people
do insane things like this given that
the series has dozens of manga volumes
and over a hundred anime episodes
there's a lot of material to cover I
think sticking close to the source
material would not only be a compelling
introduction to the nuclear ravaged
world and the weirdos living in it will
also stop people from
dragonball has never been made into a
live-action movie dragonball evolution
no no no Dragon Ball has ever ever been
made into a live-action movie all right
all right denial isn't just a river in
Egypt if there's one thing that needs to
be thrown into a body of water it's the
terrible disgusting the insult to the
fandom dragonball evolution I'm not
saying the movie would have to be the
same as the anime but as Dragon Ball is
one of the great granddaddy's of the
genre it certainly deserves better than
the piss poor effort that James Wong
offered up to longtime lovers of Goku
piccolo bulmer and go Han maybe a
two-hour feature wouldn't be able to get
into the deeper aspects of an animated
span generations but if you throw in
some of the best martial artists
character actors and CGI specialists in
the business then I think we can finally
get a sweet cam a hammy high on the big
screen that isn't an affront to my eyes
even if I have to collect all the Dragon
Balls and wish it for myself and while
we're on the subject of animes the
deserve better let's just forget that
the attack on titan movie exists and
just try again yeah my capacitor
thought-provoking crime drama set in a
dystopian future it grapples with themes
of morality mental health and
authoritarianism all while telling a
thrilling story about cops tracking down
a mysterious serial killer if you're
trying to figure out how it work as a
movie think Minority Report meets seven
the series takes place in a world where
advancements in surveillance have
allowed for people's mental states to be
monitored and the likelihood of
committing crimes predicted the series
digs into the ethics of judging people
based on their potential to commit crime
and explores what happens when someone
figures out i had to subvert the
mechanisms behind that hold on what are
you planning to do now
I'm going to stand next to this woman
named yuki funa hara and i'm going to
kill her right before your eyes the
dynamic between criminals and the
enforces the rules governing crime
coefficients and the rogue agent turning
the whole thing upside down alone would
make for an interesting viewing
experience but psychopaths has a
stunning futuristic world that would be
really cool to see on the big screen
also have you seen the rad talking under
decides who needs to die
contrary to popular belief not every
anime is nosebleeds crazy hairstyles and
shouting at the screen all right a lot
of them are but they can also be funny
witty and pretty charming to one of my
personal favorites is the psycho hero
himself Saitama the one punch man while
many action-heavy anime series user
brawling as an element's the plot
onepunch-man turbs the long battles on
their heads and adds a healthy dose of
comedic charm ah Samar as our hero can
take down any foe with one punch he's on
a quest to find an adversary that can
stand up to his strength the awesome
visuals the hilarious and eclectic cast
of superheroes mixed with old-school
super-sized monsters is just begging for
the big screen treatment in a post
Deadpool age we know there's an audience
for the hilarious large and life
characters who also wear spandex the
hardest part of this movie won't be the
visuals won't be the locations won't be
generating the giant monsters you'll be
finding a lead actor that will pull offs
item is unique and shiny look I'm Enoch
and shiny tam no
everyone loves a good underdog story and
when it comes to anime few are as
inspiring and as heartwarming as that of
macro no cheapo a bully teenager that
becomes one of Japan's most fearsome
boxes 2015 screed showed there's still
plenty of life in the sports drama genre
and hajime no ippo Japanese setting
would give it a unique new flavor its
main character is a well-meaning
hard-working optimist and someone you
can't help but love he starts off a meek
victim but when he saved from bullies by
a passing boxer he's forced to do some
soul-searching the company's happy CEO
it did now Nandi stop apologizing for
the top of Japanese boxing is full of
ups and downs it's a journey of
self-discovery where he's forced to
fight through his own physical mental
and social limitations to become a
better stronger man the series pit him
against a range of strange
larger-than-life opponents of course
there's also opposed colorful comrades
at kamigawa gym they each have their own
struggles whether it's trying to break
on to the world stage or struggling to
remain relevant despite an obvious lack
of boxing ability they also inject some
Liberty making hajime no ippo one of the
funniest animes out there
studio give me his often been compared
to Disney and howl's moving castle is
one such example that shows why these
great movies deserve to be compared with
the best this movie is one of the most
financially successful ventures in
Japanese movie history and was nominated
for an Academy Award for Best Animated
Feature and the visuals have been widely
praised by critics the world over Howl's
Moving Castle isn't quite the visual
spectacle that spirited away is but as a
story as an adventure as a tale of love
and friendship and awesome castles it's
unparalleled and it's a story that
deserves to be told in every medium it's
English dub even featured some big-name
actors such as Christian Bale and Billy
Crystal and while they might not be the
best choices for live action it shows
the scope and the integrity and the
admiration this movie has in the
industry if the likes of Peter Pan 101
Dalmatians and buting the Beast can get
on the big screen then why can't a young
girl cursed by a witch a charming wizard
with his migratory castle inhabited by
fire spirit get its own live-action
version
so those are our top picks for animes
that deserve a shot or another shot at
their very own IRL adaptation if you've
got any animated adventures you'd love
to see then leave your suggestion in the
comments section below until next time
make sure you eat your sin Z beans and
subscribe to gangs pot